brunch is a treasured mother's day
tradition
and chica inside the venetian has a
dynamic atmosphere
and delicious food here to tell us more
about their mother's day offerings
is chef lorena garcia welcome back to
the show
chef lorena i want to start with you and
what is your
favorite mother's day memory
oh my goodness my my son coming to me
and giving me a hug
the day that we opened chica right here
the venetian in las vegas
let me tell you the best mother mother's
day ever
that happened four years ago and you
know this is what we're celebrating our
anniversary besides mother's day so it's
a very special day for me
so it's a four-year anniversary of chica
it's a mother's day
celebration i do have a quick little
side note because you know i love the
restaurant
your grilled octopus it is amazing
it is unbelievable and you haven't tried
you haven't tried my peach salad let me
tell you has tangerines tomatoes
i have a little bit of a basil uh sorbet
look at this coral that we make with
beets
and then we have these apple berries and
flowers that we put right on top
if you like the octopus let me tell you
that you should try this beautiful salad
for mother's day this
is super sexy i love it because it's
sexy we also have the red snapper with
agriculture we have our beautiful
delicious barbacoa with a little bit of
kosova that we throw it right on top
just like that
and of course we serve it with tortillas
and we have it right here chica at the
venetian now going back to the dish you
have right here in front of you said
that that's made out of beets that's a
beet there
look at that can you see that oh yeah
beautiful it is i'm trying to grab
it and then the vinaigrette is actually
an ice cream it's i mean we we made a
granita
with a little bit of basil and juice and
then we we've macerated the peaches with
a little bit of red wine and honey
and then we put a little bit okay so
fresco tomato so it's super sexy super
light
and for mother's day you have to have
that you know chica it's a it's a
celebration of latin flavors
but at the same time we want the mothers
here in las vegas to feel
a spoiled and what a better place to do
it right here at the venetian
let's talk about let's talk about drinks
you have great cocktails you have great
drinks what about you mimosas on sunday
oh my god all the mimosas
you want please come to chica we have
what we do we do and fresh
pressed juices and then you know we
bring our card
and it's mimosas we're not calling
mimosa we call it mamosas
i love it thank you so much chef lorena
it is always a pleasure to have you on
the show and happy mother's day to you
for more details go to venetian.com
rocky over to you